[Music]
then royal split news submitted by cats
are better than dogs that's true [ __ ] no
I don't know I like camel you gotta find
a cat that likes you only I'm saying I
got cats and I don't know if I agree
with this I think [ __ ]
what feline [ __ ] [ __ ] yeah I think I'm
just more of a dog I don't know about
cats but my cat is he's the best what do
you call a female cat I feel it's like
all kids
I don't know cuz the [ __ ] is a dog yeah
what [ __ ] the former Malaysian king has
divorced his beauty queen wife just
weeks after the birth of their son cuz
the baby was ugly it wasn't his drama
tell me the detail he abdicated the
throne to marry this chick well he gets
the worst like a year later maybe he was
like wait wait wait I want to be a king
again oh yeah right my two stupid
decision ha ha ha ha he had a kid three
and then two two months later is when
they try to get the throne back I think
so he misses the kingship please a
Malaysian Malaysian kings did he start
buying goats no they had kings there
that's cool yeah and I didn't know that
they have nine royal families that they
rotate who has the throne with with five
ulation right the next one Game of
Thrones of Malaysia you gotta protect
the realm they had the the me go rank
party and in the nasi lemak party guess
what they do a five-year I turned it on
the throne and like it's like on a
mandolin
and there's a goal yeah this is the
first time that a royal or a monarch has
stepped down before completing the five
years and they're saying that it was
possibly because he married this chick
and so she's from Russia oh no wonder
Russians are [ __ ] hot he's 50 and
she's 27
oh that's the perfect age yeah I wonder
why he stepped down from the throne dude
that's like lord beerus would sir she
doesn't love malaysian she is hot I know
he doesn't look Malaysia so yeah he
looks like a white dude he looks more
like a walrus like Kazakh or something
huh
he looks like he plays guitar in an
indie bands like The Grateful Dead yeah
you got that asian head size though she
looks like she tells fortunes really
well so they actually got beat currently
married and then a couple months later
and then like a couple months later they
think had a big ceremony in Russia I
wonder if any girls grow up wishing that
they could marry a walrus oh yes a lot
of us if they're a keeper she could have
been a queen a queen but baby can't
because she's the Russian right well I
don't know why exactly but it's like it
seemed like everyone there and like the
palace was like no she can't be king
can't you change the rules
oh really according to Aladdin anyone
could be Sultan yeah now they have like
their son she also couldn't as a
converted or to be Muslim oh cool
yes yeah damn she must have had a really
shitty life she was actually seemed
faced over her Instagram no I want a
judge please he had a really good no
upbringing nobody that actually has the
life would do this to marry a king the
like Mary King it's a business move they
could take care of me and it's hotter in
Malaysia I just don't like when people
become successful so I just want to
imagine like she came from a poor beep
farming peasant family her parents were
alcoholics that's even more successful
yeah it should become the queen no
that's what I'm saying though
like she was desperate uh she was
desperate to do it oh maybe she was
kidnapped and then she was forced into
this life oh yeah that's a good one I
like that she was kidnapped
like not like she was wearing her whole
life no and then she was like [ __ ] it I
don't have a college education I might
as well do this this is one of her
Instagram things caption said about her
so she said my name is Oksana I was born
I'm to exploit Noxon I was born on 10th
July 1992 in Astrakhan Russia today is
my birthday I'm 27 years old I spent my
childhood and graduated from school and
taiga wrong region as a teen I went to
Oxford summer school to study English in
2009 I moved to Moscow and became a
student at this Russian University of
Economics I graduated with a bachelor's
degree in economics in 2013 in 2015 I
won the beauty contest miss Moscow then
I created my own swimwear in Beach
fashion brand at the same time I studied
at Moscow school of radio and television
so that's her background before she met
this dude she had a pretty good life she
had a pretty good life before meeting
him and so she said that they met
through this mutual cooler it's true
love I can't hide it anymore I think
it's real yes they met through this like
jeweler mutual friend and that she said
that when he introduced himself he's
like hi I'm king of Malaysia and then
she thought it was a joke so she was
like huh I'm the queen of Russia and
then like they ended up what if he
thought that was real to really know
when the baby was born that she's not
really oh yeah we're gonna be a power
couple man what the [ __ ] that's cute hi
I'm Ken ym queen of Moscow if I was a
king I would never say I'm a king yeah
but if I'm trying to hit it oh yeah
if you try to hit it you're putting all
your adventures out there house of love
of blood I'll be like Joe taxi-driver
king of yellow cab the rightful heir to
the throne what are you guys saying when
people ask what you do for a living cuz
I was struggling clown
huh I used to love making up careers Oh
like I make those raccoon hats like this
market since the because like when you
go to those events and you're like actor
or whatever I just everyone just saw
actually say actor or like musician or
whatever so I would just make up career
is boss seamstress
I never said seamstress I did say like
was a rocket engineer at one point or I
was going to school studying physics and
like I know nothing about those subjects
it was just about how much I could Bluff
we actually talked to someone who didn't
know about that that was gambling oh I
would have just played along I would
just argued with them know know what I
was talking about no one asks me what I
do know people ask you what you do well
yeah cuz I go to those event where you
have to leave your house oh yeah yeah
cuz you already meet people that you
already know I sure my house no one else
what do you want to talk to the person
or not if I do want to talk to the
person then I'll say Oh online and then
we talk about that because they're
always so curious but if I don't want to
talk to them then I'm like I just own a
gym they're like oh that's really cool
that's not as interesting to you though
yeah usually just stops there though oh
they don't want to work out now see they
go oh really I don't like [ __ ] that [ __ ]
right example I'm gonna feel guilty
exactly it's exactly that then it just
stops you said I own a gym and I'm
really preachy about diets yeah
and I'm vegan yeah people's want to know
if they can use you for something yeah
right yeah they are so [ __ ] using
yeah well I don't know cuz usually like
I'll encounter that at events and that's
when I'll be like okay I'll say the
whole internet thing whatever like I
don't know where to go what's the whole
what's your aren't you going to events
though with other influencers yeah so
that's what that's what I'm saying
that's what I'll say that but usually
like if it's like an uber driver or
something and they're asking me I'm like
oh I just I work in entertainment that's
it that's the perfect time the live why
does have an uzi collector no you're
playing mafia it's fun watch their news
anchor news anchor yeah you are a girl
oh yeah another reporter guys there's a
different you're a journalist you're a
journal know that no no that you can
find your editor the chief of staff for
the president do that's so fun I want to
imagine all these careers yes what I
love like you are that thing and then to
leave you and you get to have this whole
fabulous life that you made up that's it
so cool that's like playing Sims but
like in real life and you never talk to
them again yeah it doesn't really matter
I hate huh Uber's try to talk to me too
yeah my shut the [ __ ] up please I don't
say that I don't think that either but
like I'm you try to make conversation
I'm like I might get there in like 20
minutes
you know most of them of teams I think
like an earlier uber days it was more
like that talking I mean I didn't take a
ton of movers I don't know but the now
like just comparing from my past
uber experience to current uber
experience it seems like a lot more uber
drivers don't spark or spark up
conversations as much it's not my last
crazy this old Mexican guy he played me
the album that his friend recorded yeah
you wanna listen to my favorite what if
it's his but he's just like hoping that
he gets discovered I don't know you lady
he's like this Mexican dude and then he
was like you want to listen to it online
okay and then I and then it was so it
was a he's a political rock star and
it's all in Spanish oh my god I don't
even know if I look like I speak Spanish
I'm just sitting in the back seat the
whole time looks pretty good I'm like
yeah
perfect one to hear it because you're
just judging it by the musicality of it
he's just screaming the whole time it's
a political medal political math in
Spanish and it's just like hard guitar
[ __ ]
so women's rights metal band what did he
explain that it was political or did he
said it's also is if it's his friend
from the 60s so also all the things he's
fighting about doesn't matter anymore
interracial marriage should be legal
yeah that's all over now I'm just
sitting down the backfill my god damn it
like in the war and you know it's
throwback throwbacks I know and so he
said like lie that you're a Bitcoin
clogged because one of my last super
rides to the airport so it's long right
yeah it was the guy who was like
explaining to me how to invest in
cryptocurrency was he a part of big
connect like he had like like pamphlets
and stuff he gave to me I like take a
picture of this and I so I was actually
yeah there's a pretty informational but
I was like crypto currencies yeah
there's a lot of pyramid scam you coin
things yeah they try to recruit you in
the last super driver that took us to
the airport was bragging about how his
the last person he drove was a super big
celebrity on Instagram and he was like
going all off and I guess this picked
this guy had all these pictures of cash
on his Instagram he's like this guy's
making so much money with his followers
and he's like showing us and this guy
has like 30,000 Instagram followers and
he just has like stacks of like money
maybe three did you guys show him yours
and use the last one you're my new story
yeah that's what we like like to play
along when we're like holy [ __ ] that guy
was in your car yeah you guys
crazy people yeah we were just like wow
you got he was sitting right here right
here in this spot here [ __ ]
they're like feels this they were like
yeah yeah yeah I asked him like how do
you get so many followers he says he
just post pictures he says that like
people just come in like like his
pictures picture we gotta go we gotta go
people observe together cuz I love I
love that [ __ ]
[Music]
[Music]